o creen dice que moscú ha dado por
finalizada la primera fase de esta
guerra porque las tropas ucranianas le
han asestado un duro golpe al ejército
de moscú el mandatario ucraniano gladyr
michelle es ya también dicho que esto
debería ser a retomar el diálogo de una
forma rápida y justa sin embargo el
futuro de este país todavía es una
incógnita y las versiones todavía
difieren un ejemplo son las bajas de
soldados rusos según quiera habrían
fallecido más de 16.000 efectivos de
moscú mientras que moscú reconoce sólo
la muerte de 1.300 soldados de su país
esto demuestra que la propaganda sigue
siendo una constante en esta guerra que
dura desde hace más de un mes mientras
también incierta sigue siendo la
situación en algunas ciudades como
gerson según el pentágono rusia estaría
perdiendo el control de partes de esta
urbe que recordemos en la más grande de
ucrania tomada por rusia en esta semana
sin embargo estas informaciones no han
podido ser verificadas de una forma
independiente